I've been trying to donate to
coronavirus and it is very difficult and
I'll tell you why they don't need money
as much as they need supplies they need
masks they need ventilators I cannot
make a ventilator in my West Hollywood
apartment I lack the skill I lack the
material I don't know what it is I can't
I could I make masks I don't know but I
don't think I can and the masks that I
make would just be insulting it would be
stupid
so anticipating that this is a larger
economic problem of course it impacts
lots of people I guess somebody told me
today they said you could just donate to
a food bank and all right but guys guys
guys how sexy is donating to a food bank
let's get real does anybody want to
donate anonymously to a food bank I want
to donate to something where I can can
show the world that I'm doing it so I
can inspire them I want a photo of me
outside cedars-sinai I want two doctors
and a nurse crouched on the floor
holding their stethoscopes and I want to
be behind them with my hand on each of
their backs and I want that photo I
don't need to go anonymously donate to a
food bank I want something big something
glossy a little sexy looks sexy I know
they're going through with doctors and
nurses I that I know that and it's
[ __ ] sucks out there and I want to
help them but I also want to be
photographed doing it and if that makes
me a bad person
fine if that make if you don't want to
listen to the show anymore or then fine
I want to be photographed helping I'm
not saying any of the documentary about
me helping that wouldn't be horrible
either but I want to still photograph or
a few of them of me helping in whatever
capacity I help
I want that's all so if there's a way
for me to help that is a little sexy
please let me know a little bit of a
photo-op I appreciate all the first
responders and nurses and doctors taking
time away from patients to send me
messages on Instagram so I know what's
going on for my show I appreciate that
don't stop keep sending those messages
just keep sending them doesn't matter
what the hell's going on in there keep
me abreast of all the local developments
on the ground please it's another
pandemic all my relatives are gonna
somehow survive great 9/11 the financial
crisis every kind of cancer they're
unbeatable these people the boomers are
you can't get him can't get him they're
gonna they're gonna walk around like
Lazarus raised from the dead complaining
about the temperature of shrimp what's
wrong as it did you leave it out for too
long I'm telling you you're not gonna
beat the boom buddy people think this is
this virus the boomer remover think not
it'll get some people and that's [ __ ]
tragic but the boomers are gonna be back
and they're gonna be back with a
vengeance this is their Holocaust they
are good there will be you think the
boomers were bad before they are gonna
talk about covert 19 the way people talk
about Krystal mock I'm telling you
they're not gonna let it go you'd think
they were annoying before these
[ __ ] are gonna go hard they're
gonna go hard they'll Stella nurse right
to her face that she doesn't know [ __ ]
they'll be like well you don't even
where were you I was a nurse on the
front line the front lines are what yeah
young I was old in my house having to be
racist in my home and not at the local
restaurant